what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
Rob core I know y'all have been waiting
pay y'all have been waiting patient
y'all have been struggling with regards
to the Walking Dead I know you guys have
been have been dying to know like what
happens in the whisper war man like I
need to know what happened I need to
know what happened after the last last
volume so with regards to the whisper
warm and this is this is where things
get interesting things get wild man the
ending in the whisper Wars is crazy it's
Kurt as a son so again what we had
talked about in the last volume was a
negan basically escaped right you know
this young kid Brandon who is pissed off
at brick engineered negan's escape and
Brandon was like look we're going to get
you to the whispers you're going to
spill the beans on everything you know
and we're gonna use the whispers and
we're going to take out Rick in his
group you know and we're gonna call it a
day the issue was that negan was like
nope and [ __ ] killed Brandon and then
went off to the whisperers on his own
right so uh what this does is this picks
up immediately after the end of that the
funny thing is keep in mind you know we
have all these different guys we have
Dwight you know what the I guess the
second-in-command - Meegan when negan
was run into Savior's ah you know he's
the one that's running the Savior's at
the moment although he's kind of away
from the for the main Savior base for
the most part ah but we basically had
them you know kind of keep and watch
because keep in mind the whole idea was
that when negan escaped Rick sent a
handful of people out but said no one
goes into the board no one crosses the
borders of the Savior's if you don't
have to because the Savior said look if
you cross our borders we're gonna go to
war but was negan showing up here
Dwight's immediate responses shoot it
kill him shoot him on sight
I don't just shoot him right now be done
with it and this is kind of crazy
because the people that Dwight are with
remember these are the new guys these
are the ones that don't know about negan
and Weiss like look you do not know this
guy the way I know him if we shoot him
now it'll solve all of our problems well
thank God they don't because when when
negan shows up of course he kind of
talks to white a little bit talks to a
little bit even goes to reach for
Lucille he goes to reach for is bad and
Dwight's like don't even think about it
and so they basically just kind of take
him off you know to the to go meet Rick
well the cool thing in the aftermath of
this is that when when negan gets to
Rick's he shows in the head of alpha and
it's just like yeah I chilled her now
the cool thing is a rich like I don't
know whether to
believe you or not you know but he's
like hey look like it literally is her
this is the funny situation is because
rich like why should I trust you like
you've been gone for a week you
literally tried to kill me when you were
writing the savior's why should I trust
you he's like because it's the same
reason that I didn't leave when my cell
was accidentally left unlocked you know
it's the same reason that I basically
escaped with Brandon killed alpha and
brought her head back I'm trying to show
you that I'm a good guy I'm trying to
show you that I'm on your side this kind
of kind of the irony of the whole thing
because what negan's done it just makes
things worse that's all he's done here
and it's hilarious it's like a person
who's like hey look I'm going to show
you how capable of a cook I am so they
try to cook dinner and they burn the
house down in the process it's like look
your heart was in the right place but
like you screwed up really bad like you
screwed up really really bad and so
that's kind of the issue that rick has
to contend with now because with negan
crossing over the borders with Meghan
killing alpha beta as he stood is not
going to take off as role he's just like
we're going to avenge her death the
whispers are going to war with Rick now
this was already intended right Rick was
already like we're going to go to war
with them like we're going to go there
we're going to wipe them out but what
this did is this basically took away the
element of surprise
because even if Rick was able to take
the whisperers by surprise it wouldn't
matter because with negan crossing over
to their borders killing alpha and then
leaving no prepping for war so it's not
like Rick and his guys could just show
up in the Whisperer camp and take them
by surprise
take them unawares they're geared up
they're ready for battle and so because
it's really just grabbing everyone they
can and trying to bring them over I mean
you got people from the hilltop that are
coming over you have a couple people
from the from the kingdom that are
coming over but here's the funny thing
about this it's what the death of
Ezekiel William is essentially running
the show now of course William being one
of the guys who was a prominent under
Ezekiel's rule but he's also running
into some various issues especially from
other people who were essentially
standing against him one of the people
that's essentially standing up here -
William is Zachary and this is kind of a
crazy situation because Zachary and
William had this weird situation in the
sense that with no absolute or at least
it seems like no one person and absolute
power that a lot of people are looking
to William but a lot of people are also
questioning his leadership and that's
par for the course right like that's
what Kirkman is always doing curtain
basically says hey look things run a
certain way until like that leaders gone
and then when that leader is gone things
fall into disarray people begin to look
at things with a
Lance and I we saw that with uh with
Maggie right like Nagi took over the
hilltop colony she basically was the one
running the show but there were some
people that didn't ally themselves with
her they were just like I we don't
really see her as a legitimate leader we
see Gregory as a legitimate leader and
even after Gregory was killed they still
looked at Maggie with slanted eyes it's
the same thing here with regards to with
regards to William not everybody looks
at him as a legitimate leader not
everybody says he's a God that needs to
be running the show now the cool thing
about this is William starts considering
the prospect of getting rid of people
who get in his way just like people
normally should in these particular
roles when you're dealing with warfare
there are people who are real with you
and then the people who are dead and so
because of that it's an interesting
situation in terms of how you function
in this capacity and so what we do is we
pick up with Andrea and Rick and this is
actually a pretty significant
conversation here the reason why is
because Rick basically sat down with
negan and said okay fine here's how
things are going to be you have have
somewhat earned our trust but not really
and so he's like negan is gonna have the
opportunity to kind of live out in
no-man's land by himself isolated away
from everybody else but until he gets
that he's going to have to earn it but
the issue here is that negan's not being
thrown back in prison again
but even Rick asked us Andrea do you
agree with my decision do you think it's
the right one Andrea's responses well I
mean do what you got to do I guess you
know but at the end of the day the big
question that she has is is negan a guy
to be trusted it's negan someone that
you can put your faith in to have your
back when you need it or will Meegan
just wait for the right opportunity to
be you know for you to be at your most
vulnerable kill you and then take your
place that's the question that Andrea is
asking and that's the question that Rick
is pondering it's the big thing in the
back of his mind the entire time and so
they trust of this negan is basically
assigned to Dwight right you know twice
like or Rick's like Dwight is going to
keep an eye on negan the entire time
that he's out there but again there also
prepping for the arrival of the
whisperers knowing they're going to war
so what they do is they have one of
their guys basically go up they have one
of the guys Gabriel go up to a to a
water tower to keep an eye out the
problem is that as soon as Gabriel gets
up there he sees a mountain of zombies
he sees hundreds of zombies all heading
their direction well at this point panic
sets in because no one knows no one has
any idea this is coming
Gabriel's just like there's hundreds of
zombies that are heading over here
there's whispers probably mixed with
them you've got people who are reading
books cleaning out their guns you've got
people who are smoking cigarettes you
have people doing a multitude of
different things but none of them are
prepared for battle
none of
Mr prep for war when these zombies come
rolling in they're basically going to be
taken by surprise and that's almost
exactly what happens now the issue here
is that where Gabriel tries to bail out
tries to get down tries to tell
everybody what's going on he's tripped
up and his attempts to try to get down
the ladder
he's killed by beta and then he's
consumed by the zombies that are walking
by and so at this point it's really just
up to everybody else to kind of try to
understand or at least try to rally to
their cause with these walkers showing
up now this is where things become
beneficial because keep in mind Dwight's
been teaching everybody how to shoot
he's basically been the leader of their
army we don't really get any specifics
in terms of how far his military
training goes we're basically told that
he has some measure of military training
we don't know if he was like a Navy SEAL
we don't know if he was just a guy who
was part of the army and that was really
about the extent of it he was just some
enlisted man and that was really about
it we don't know you know how far his
whole experience goes but what he does
do is he rallies them all together the
funny thing about this is that negan's
not given a weapon nick is not given a
gun he's the one guy that's doing
nothing he's like really he was like
we're in the middle of a war and no
one's going to give me a gun like no
one's going to give me a weapon I'm just
going to have to sit here and watch
everything unfold and that's really what
happens but this was actually cool
because remember walkers were just slow
moving they're slow moving and the
whispers have to move with them and so
because of that as long as they can keep
the numbers relatively thin you know
they should be able to take them out the
issue is that the closer the walkers get
a little more adventurous the whisperers
become and they start moving out and
begin flashing it people will and of
course you know after this chaos reigned
supreme and that's really what is up
happening I mean the lines aren't really
falling so much as people are beginning
to fall now for the most part of the
defense is there I mean you've got guys
when the kingdom that finally show up
you know they finally make their way out
there but it's really just this idea
that the questions being asked can they
maintain these lines can they keep it
held together can they stay on focus so
it's really comedies gathering of forces
from a multitude of different places
it's not a full contingent like a whole
great big huge thing but it's a
gathering of forces I mean you got
Michonne you have you have Jesus now you
have a few people out there you know who
show up and they're really able to hold
them off and full effect to be honest
they're able to do pretty damn well the
issue with this is that the numbers just
keep coming the zombies just keep coming
and that's one of the greatest things
about The Walking Dead right that's one
of the things we love so much about this
it was a really really good quote from
World Wars
and it was when the main character was
interviewing Todd weyni oh they were
talking about the Battle of Yonkers and
he said that when people think about
major warfare they name them
campaigns like operation shock and awe
it's like well what do you do when you
go against an enemy that can't be
shocked an enemy that can't be on enemy
that doesn't get scared and enemy just
let's just fill with a desire for flesh
and just keeps on coming and coming and
coming
all you can never really do is just hold
them off as best you can and so because
of this with dwight being pinned down
you know it's like being attached by
beta really what he does he grabs what
little you know energy he has he grabs
Lucille and he throws it at negan and
Egan says welcome home baby like it is
beautiful because it's just it's so
awesome it's like we finally have Meegan
and Lucille United and I never thought
I'd be so excited to see a man and a
baseball bat United like I never thought
it would just look Jeff yes we know
negan finally give his baseball bat back
like I never would have thought that I'd
say that before but I did like I was
going through this and I was like oh my
god he gets he gets Lucille back and
it's so cool to see because it's like it
makes him complete right like up until
this point it was just like parts of me
again you know up until this point it
was just like yo negan is just not whole
because he doesn't have a seal but once
he has Lucille you know he goes to work
I mean he literally Meegan starts
getting himself in the ass-kicking
business and business is good and he
starts tearing through everybody the
problem with this is that when he's
attacking bata and he goes to mentally
crack him over with a baseball bat
Lucille breaks Lucille dies Lucille is
dead guys and it's just one of the
crushing things one of the most crushing
things because negan just starts crying
he's just like no we don't you know
instead this was crushing thing because
it's like you feel for right I mean and
this is why this is kind of important
this is why we feel matters for people
that are familiar with the walking dead
people that have never read the comics
people who don't know the origin story
of negan they just kind of see there's a
wocket you know as a baseball bat
they're just like whatever you know it's
a baseball bat who cares the important
thing to keep in mind here is that
negan's wife was named Lucille he named
his baseball bat Lucille in order to
basically keep his wife's memory alive
with his baseball bat being destroyed
it's like the memory abuse of Lucille is
gone the memory of Lucille isn't there
anymore and so because of that you know
again these these walkers are continuing
forward you know these walkers are
continuing on the battle just kind of
continues to rage albeit with people
trying to catch their breath here and
there but at the end of the day there
seemed to be a whole lot of ability in
terms of you know then being able to
stave it off and said they're doing what
they can when they can but that's about
it instead what happens is Dwight has
this genius idea do I says When in Rome
do what the Romans do you know what
we're going to do is we're literally
going to grab whatever whispers we can
we're going to strip off their skins
we're going to put them on and then
we're going to go into the zombie horde
and we're going to start killing
whispers and it's a genius idea because
it literally allows them to carry out
their goal to basically wage war against
the whispers and fight the whispers on
their own territory it's classic Sun Tzu
art of war that's basically what it is
when you're fighting a war and you're on
unfamiliar territory go to familiar
territory have them fight on your terms
and that's exactly what happens it's
really like Michonne it's Dwight a few
other people just sort of roaming
through the script now keep in mind at
this point
betas been injured and so beta is
basically kind of being carried off
being moved by some of the other
whispers to the point that he's like
look we got to go back we have to what
we have to do is we have to enact Plan B
now what plan B is we don't entirely
know instead what we do is we pick up
with this this second assault and the
second assault comes in the form of the
whispers who have basically moved a
zombie horde towards the direction of
the hilltop colony and it's kind of
crazy here because everybody comes with
becomes aware of the fact that whispers
are there when flaming arrows come
flying over the wall and this is why the
whispers are so capable right because we
would look at them and say well they're
guys you just walk around I just kind of
stab people around zombies so on and so
forth you know but zombies use
presumably a sense of smell to determine
who's human and who's not because of
that the whispers can just kind of move
around arbitrarily known as Ami's pay no
attention to them they can fire off
arrows you know flaming arrows a zombies
don't have any reason to believe it came
from them because as far as the zombies
know the whisperers are zombies and so
they're basically invisible to these
guys they can ask you know relatively
speaking without drawing too much
attention but the idea here is that they
start tearing through you know fighting
through the entirety of the hills not
Kali now the other half of this and this
is actually something really really cool
is that alphas daughter basically turns
against the whispers because remember
the entire reason why the whispers are
here as a hilltop is half to take out
the hilltops defenses but the other half
is to grab the daughter of alpha and
bring her back and of course about her
so look alpha has fallen alphas gone and
the daughters like I don't care I'm not
part of you anymore I'm not part of your
group and she just starts picking out
all these different whispers now of
course you know that the hilltops
to hold its own the issue here is that
between Sophia fighting between you know
Cora fighting real everybody who can
fight is fighting it's really them kind
of making this last stand at the Alamo
in a sense that everything is just
burning down around them so sure you
know they were able to keep themselves
alive but every situation in the hilltop
you know everything inside the hilltop
is basically gone everything worth
fighting for is gone in its entirety and
so because of this we have this entire
assault being looked at by beta invaded
like we have to keep going we still have
to launch Plan B so the idea is what in
the heck is going on behind Plan B one
in the world is taking place here what
are the whispers final intention so what
we do is we pick up with with Dwight and
his various guys you know showing up at
the hilltop everybody's like where were
you at four hours ago you know that kind
of crazy response but it's interesting
to see the situation because those
people really kind of rallying after
this conflict rallying after this war
and even the brick and everybody else
goes to say hey look we won that's
basically what happens when Dwight and
everybody starts showing up when Eugene
shows up with this you know with these
crates and crates and crates of ammo
what everybody starts coming back to the
Alexandria say so it's like yeah man we
won like we managed to fight them off we
basically defeated the whispers you know
their leaders dead their forces have
been pushed to the brink of almost
complete and total destruction there's
nothing left here well then this is when
we learn what Plan B is when Dwight's
talking to brick Ron you know he's like
yeah man we did it you know I couldn't
believe we pulled it off it was
basically a handful of us there were
hundreds of walkers that came through
here we got rid of them all we won the
war rich responses hundreds do this war
is far from over
Rick races off and this is when we find
out what Plan B is that the the the
whispers are moving a zombie horde
toward Alexandria over 10,000 strong ten
thousand zombies at least being moved to
Alexandria and they're going to overrun
that place there's no way to defend
against the zombie horde of this size
when that being said guys this brings it
into the whisper war there are a couple
themes that we didn't run over with
regards like the Savior's kind of you
know taking up or intend to take up arms
against Rick but again I really want to
focus on the whisper war in this video
because I don't really know what
direction things are going to go after
this I mean this is literally as current
as we get with the Walking Dead like we
finish the story arc did just finish so
we are 100% current it what we do next
I'm not sure I guess I can cover older
stories until the new ones come out but
uh yeah like it is it is wild man like
things are going to get insane anyway
guys yeah we're going to bring this
video to an end let me know what you
think down in the in the comments
section you guys think about this whole
Walking Dead thing because I love
Kurtzman's Walking Dead it's absolutely
amazing but yeah I will catch you all
later peace